here's to the futures no mr. right now
Gabriella and Troy you've got to be one
of the most popular Disney Channel
couples of all time you guys have broken
up on multiple occasions making us ball
our eyes out again and again so we hope
you don't take it personally but you
guys didn't make the cut this time
around since you're the original Disney
Channel OTP we figured you could help us
judge these recent breakups from afar
it's like the whole world is against us
being together
[Music]
it's always nice to have some Disney
veterans on board the Disney Channel has
a knack for creating some of the best
on-screen couples of all time but Disney
knows that it's all about the drama
which is why they create some super sad
breakup scenarios to watch until the end
to see if you agree with our number one
pick let's jump right in Spencer and
Teddy it feels like forever ago that
good luck charlie aired on the Disney
Channel but true fans still remember
Spencer and Heidi's on-and-off
relationship these two were hot and cold
but we couldn't help but root for them
even after Spencer tried to date two
girls at the same time in season one
Spencer's my boyfriend and now Spencer's
my boyfriend
the Sundy Shep chooses to call it quits
when Spencer gets admitted to a school
in Boston and the couple breaks things
off because we're saying goodbye Charlie
and it's very hard thing to do this
moment was truly heartbreaking Justin
and Juliet can someone get us a tissue
please we're about to relive one of
these saddest Disney Channel breakups of
all time who could forget about Justin
and Juliet's beautiful forbidden romance
Wizards of Waverly Place had plenty of
on-screen relationships to choose from
but Justin and Juliet's was simply the
best things between the happy couple
became shaky when Juliet was scratched
by Mason causing her appearance to match
just how old she truly was keep you
right here
this moment was so sad at hurt but
thankfully the couple worked things out
in the end
Alex and Mason but Juliet and Justin
weren't the only ones who had a rocky
relationship Alex and Mason also
suffered a terrible breakup that
seriously impacted their viewers
everything went south when Mason saw
Juliet and accidentally blurted out that
he still loved her right in front of
Alex you and I would be so great
together
Alex quickly leaves the scene but the
break-up is far from over
Mason finds Alex and apologizes again
but she refuses to get back together
either Austin and Ally
fans couldn't get enough of this couple
which is why it hurts so bad when they
called it quits in the episode
relationship and red carpets we just
aren't meant to be together although the
couple would get back together in the
end of the episode the break-up was
super rough everything went downhill
when Austin told Ally that he needed to
keep their relationship a secret on top
of that Ali was going on tour for three
months which only made things worse
Ali chose to break up with Austin and
our hearts broke when he told her Miley
and Jessi Disney's Hannah Montana was
one of the bests it comes ever and we
loved Miley and Jessie's relationship
after choosing to be with Jesse and
telling him the truth about her alter
ego Miley was finally living her best
life but when news got out that Hannah
Montana's boyfriend was cheating on her
with the Miley Jessi quickly realized
that dating an undercover star wasn't
all butterflies and rainbows Jessi broke
things off with Miley saying that he
couldn't be with Hannah and Miley at the
same time if I'm dating Hannah now I'm
cheating on Miley and if I'm dating
Miley then I'm the jerk who broke Hannah
Montana's heart luckily their split
lasted less than an episode sunny and
Chad in season 2 episode 25 of sunny
with a chance we find out that Chad will
always have an issue with sharing his
thunder just when sunny thought Chad
could be the one for her he proved her
wrong by asking for a vote recount you
did what now
sunny chose to break up with Chad after
realizing that he would always put
himself first and she told him Chad
there are no second chances
ouch Skye and Shawn if you were a fan of
the lodge you're probably still kind of
angry with the way things left off
between sky and Shawn the couple breaks
up in season 2 episode 14 and a scene is
sort of hard to watch when sky tries to
tell Shawn that they shouldn't be
together he quickly realizes that she
has feelings for Ben and you think that
each was wrong guy and walks away we
needed more closure Disney Maddie and
diggie the Maggie and diggie ship wasn't
for everyone and some fans were outraged
when Maddie forgave diggie and chose him
over Josh lovey can't deny that their
breakup scene got us right in the fields
after finding out that diggie was
leaving again
Maddie realized that she just couldn't
be the supportive long-distance
girlfriend he needed her to be Zack and
Maya is there anyone who didn't enjoy
watching suite life on deck yeah we
didn't think so Zack and Maya's breakup
scene wasn't an easy one to accept Maya
broke things off with Zack because she
didn't want to have a long-distance
relationship and he was torn still he
and Maya's short relationship did help
him grow as a person but in our opinion
the saddest Disney Channel breakup of
all time went down between live and hold
him if tears weren't streaming down your
face when Holden broke things off with
Liv you are one strong human being
Maddie's my sister and if she needs me
to do something for her I'm going to
Holden breaks up with Liv when he finds
out that she values diggie and Maddie's
feelings over his own we need to break
up so there you have it guys the 10
saddest breakups in Disney Channel
History which on-screen couple was your
OTP tell us in the comments and that's a
wrap don't forget to Like and subscribe
to the things so you never miss another
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]